thank you
[Music]
so I just wanted to make you guys aware
of a very beautiful ribbon cutting
ceremony oh I love those in the Congo
and we're gonna watch it together oh
I gotta replay it oh [ __ ]
oh wait what what
oh oh
together oh my God the ribbon was
holding it together no
it literally happened as soon as he cut
it yeah
what that ribbon cutting was for the
bridge for the bridge yeah wait is it
because of the ribbon or because there's
just too many people on the bridge
there's probably so many people on the
bridge but the ribbon was the cat the
straw of the cow's back yeah I think it
was also not probably a very I like that
there's like Navy Seals at the ribbon
cutting ceremony that's like some like
cartoon [ __ ] it's like everything it is
every other country like they got like
just random Commandos in different
places I know right I feel like in the
Congo they got those there's always
dudes and Army fatigues and [ __ ]
or like there's like some guy with like
so many [ __ ] ribbons it goes to his
hip yeah yeah that's how you know he's
[ __ ] in like non-military events like
imagine we had a Raising Cane's Grand
Oak
I like the not generals but the fatigues
guys with the sunglasses on with the
hats those guys are Green Beret guys
what are you doing it's like assault
rifles with the [ __ ] AK-47 you're
wearing like okay and then bullets here
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like somebody's baby shower and
they got like five [ __ ] gorilla
members they gotta represent they gotta
be protective it's fully uniform full
uniform With Grenades and [ __ ] like dude
it's a baby shower for raising canes
grand opening we should do that I'm
gonna do that for jumby's grand opening
we're on some [ __ ] military dudes and
[ __ ] hire some Black Water Guys
Special Forces have one of those pickup
trucks with the machine gun
the ones from Cancun and a guy who is it
has never smiled once in his life
sitting on it and he's just sitting up
there the whole time the terrorist
Tacoma yeah terrorist Tacoma Bob Isis
Toyota
those are great
uh so dignitaries gathered for the very
exciting day to inaugurate a Footbridge
in the capital of the Democratic
Republic of Congo only for the structure
to immediately collapse beneath their
feet to the barely concealed Delight of
onlookers oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] hilarious
it's universal language people following
is funny
um
at the same time the organizer cut the
ribbon of the ceremony he was very
excited about this
um the bridge buckled and collapsed both
its handrails broke off and the central
section slumped into a stream a couple
meters below dignitaries shouted damn
they were doused in water VIPs struggled
to get off the crumpled wreck nobody was
reported to have been hurt this is the
best kind of Comedy right yeah I love it
it's the best one people are dead but
the guy that built the bridge is like oh
[ __ ] they need to fire that engineer
dude maybe it's the same guy who built
uh the guard is a Galaxy ride or some
[ __ ] oh what happened to them that's
good he's like he's like you guys ready
for the ride yeah oh my God so you
didn't want that there was a bridge here
like in the 50s or some [ __ ] and it's
like um they study this in like
engineering school of how they [ __ ] it
up so bad and you can see pictures of
the bridge it starts wobbling like
there's cars on it and the bridge starts
wobbling like this like it looks like a
[ __ ] wave like in the water and it
starts going like that and [ __ ] and it
[ __ ] breaks oh my God I think it was
in Seattle or is that the one during the
earthquake and it was like
no it was it was just a bad design so
it's like wind and just regular like oh
yeah normally just made the bridge just
[ __ ] go like this and it snapped dude
my favorite [ __ ] is this guy down here
oh and he's holding a bottle of
champagne
what is that what is that bridge
connecting it looks like what's even
under it I have no [ __ ] idea that
looks like a little river or something
yeah this is a river dock where you put
like your fishing boat it almost looks
like an inconsequential Bridge yeah
it just says Footbridge everyone else is
just jumping over it yeah because nobody
fell in the water it's just like it just
hit the ground
it wasn't anything it wasn't like
utility based but I feel like like in
areas like that those bridges are
probably a big deal they should look
that should look like a bridge building
pageant like a bridge building contest
last place
[Laughter]
that would make sense and they're just
testing to see how many people they can
get on it oh it didn't pass
because before that [ __ ] they probably
had to swim in that River with
alligators and [ __ ] yeah stepping over I
know now it's like dude now they can't
go to school they're like it's a new
[ __ ] day guys we're gonna get so much
more stuff you don't have the [ __ ]
assuming alligators to go to the [ __ ]
school like our shoes aren't gonna get
wet yeah it's gonna be crazy we have to
wear water shoes to school every day
small too huh yeah it looked like a dry
riverbed so what I'm assuming is that
it's one of those like seasonal flood
rivers or like maybe like when it's dry
season they can walk through yeah but
then when it's wet season like they're
just like oh that shit's flooded so
their Village is not connected well the
confusing part for me
that I I wanted to show you guys is it
people are in the back here
what on the other side and they're
walking on a bridge behind it I think
that's where it collapses wait wait what
breaks in the middle oh the other one
there's the one behind it oh that looks
like a like a Wood Bridge like a like
made out of logs looks like it works
though yeah that was probably like the
old one that's more of a ramp let's be
real that's a ramp dude because that one
can't carry like a push cart well maybe
maybe that's the construction Bridge the
way that like buildings that are being
built have a have an elevator for the
construction guys but you know what's
funny is right when they cut the rope or
the ribbon the two handrails fell off
immediately yeah
you know in Vietnam they have bamboo
Bridges with just two poles of bamboo
and like little sticks to hold those
dude and you could just walk on those
and those never break holy [ __ ] we're
gonna get some bamboo because Vietnamese
people weigh light but people people
don't talk about the spiders though
bamboo has a bunch of spiders in there I
don't like that are you sure
this bridge is like maybe they [ __ ]
got it donated from the [ __ ]
Universal tram ride or something it
looks like tons of pieces from different
things like I thought I actually thought
that was actually a bridge the back of a
semi truck or like a flatbed or
something connected to a piece of wood
it looked like it was Frankenstein
together what do you think they do after
this you think they go celebrate it or
like because they're already they're
already ready to celebrate I feel like
the engineer gets his brains blown out I
know 15 people all look in the bridge
like this ah [ __ ] what are we doing
whatever warlord was there that day he
is not happy dude he's all like fun it
is crazy that they had a ceremony over
this bridge yeah that must be a big deal
Bridge or the guy with the champagne
walks up and he sees it collapse turns
around like all right because he was
gonna break it like like you know when
they build the boat he was gonna break
it and he goes it breaks even more do
you think he's like do you think he sees
a collapse he's like
I think I know how I [ __ ] up
like you need like he finally realized
okay he sees the equation and where he I
think I know what it did wrong he forgot
to screw one thing yeah well what if it
wasn't the engineer what if it was like
Bob and [ __ ] and he was like Bob I told
you the [ __ ] last bolt and he goes oh
the last bowl
oh together he's like hey Bob where's
the last ball and then Bob's like Bob's
like
and then they all like start laughing
yeah
so I felt that before when I was moving
to Vegas right and they like they
dissect the movers they disassemble like
your furniture or whatever and then they
they build it back up in your new in
your new place and they put the bed
frame up and then I'm like did you you
know follow that you just followed
exactly how you disassembled to assembly
oh yeah all the screws or whatever's in
the right place and okay cool you go and
he's like this and like three screws and
they're like what the [ __ ] no oh dude I
don't know what happened and then you
lift up the mattress and they only like
screwed like
at least they're still there for that
yeah it's like that yeah where they yeah
or the bed wasn't strong enough for you
for me yeah it was before it's the same
thing yeah
I got my moped back after getting my
brakes fixed and then the first thing I
see is that there is like a screw like
super loose and I'm like oh I gotta this
one goes oh oh I forgot to yeah let me
fix that for you and he fixes it right
and I was like there's no more and he
goes yeah everything's good all right so
I go home and then like my like my
seat's rattling oh I know what is this
and then like I pop it open and what he
did was he had all the screws just like
in you know like before you tie it right
it's just loose so you so you know where
they're supposed to hand tightened yeah
yeah they're not even hand tightened
they're just like sitting on top of it
so I was like oh [ __ ] so I tightened
everything up oh that's no safe people
just like I don't know why they skip on
the screws they just rush through life
or what's gone it's not for them bro
it's not for them that's what I think I
think if it's for you you try to do
everything exactly right if it's not for
you you're gonna cut some corners but
then if that's your business you know
bro I know dude talk to Anthony leaves
cutting corners on this [ __ ] noodle
business
non-stop somebody screws in the noodles
I don't know it makes it all vegan issue
I've heard all kinds of [ __ ] like every
fifth noodle is just plastic well if you
take the noodles out the standard noodle
Leaf is like this long this isn't like
right here yeah I measured so inside It
says 55 grams of wet noodles I measured
it yep
I told you that's false advertising
that's false advertising we had Bob
messed up my macros dude I had to
recalculate everything when Bobby
hundreds was here yesterday and he's
talking about Reinventing himself every
day I'm like oh is that why it takes
Anthony Lee 24 months to have the spicy
version of the noodle
[Laughter]
24 months
[Music]
[Music]